when we are
willing to put ourselves at risk to be
there for someone right don't worry if
this goes south i will be there for you
um which
may mean working late it may mean
working extra hours maybe putting our
reputations on the line i mean there's a
lot of things that that takes um
but when we genuinely promise to be
there for someone um um
uh and and it has to be genuine
because if it gets tested it's it's very
easy to find out if it was genuine or
not
um but if it's genuine then then it's
repaid remarkably let me give you a
silly example um let's say that
so i talk about this sometimes which is
the giving of time and energy is more
powerful than the giving of money you
can't build trust with money so paying
somebody bonuses and giving somebody a
big salary though feels nice is not
earning or building any trust whatsoever
you cannot pay for trust
um and here's the example um let's say
you're
moving house
um and one of your friends says you know
what
i wanna help you we've been friends for
years um i'm gonna pay for the moving
van here's five thousand dollars and the
moving van let me know how it goes have
a great move that's really generous
right
another friend says you know what i want
to help you move and they come over the
week before and they're sitting in your
house packing boxes they're
sweat dripping down their brow they're
there with you all day they're there to
help load the truck they're there to
help unload the truck they're they're
there um uh to unwrap everything
right they paid zero money
they give you time and energy which are
non-redeemable commodities money we make
money we spend money we make money back
it's a redeemable commodity time and
energy are non-redeemable commodities
and so when someone gives us something
that they cannot get back
it has a much more powerful effect on
how we feel so now both those people
call you another time and say i need
your help which one are you more apt to
help you want to give you money or the
one who gave you time and energy and
this this is a good lesson for
leadership as well giving our time and
energy is often more powerful than
simply just throwing money at someone